did you uh that you we so the caller
daddy drama did you did you we I hate
when you record something and then like
that night holy [ __ ] son sit happens cuz
then we had a bunch of comments that
were like um yeah but did you see Alex's
response because no we did it was it no
we didn't we were [ __ ] recorded into
these before I hate that [ __ ] I just
want to scream in my computer screen
know but yet I did not watch the truth
video that's too long but it's actually
pretty good I watched the whole thing
yeah and she just says it she's I'm
having like it's too long to watch right
now but she um this should too long yeah
she she basically comes out with her her
side it matches Dave's perfectly okay
turns out it was all they were right he
was also fiha and this dude that she was
dating and now the best part is is that
Alex gets to keep the podcast what if
and the other girl got [ __ ] cut she's
out fired nothing and social issue I'm
guessing but like wow that's what what
could she sue for what could she
possibly sue for I have no idea no idea
you're gonna go to war with barstool CEO
unless your boyfriend is bankrolling
your whole lawsuit there's no way she'd
not be that rich she's just an exec I
mean people's you know dudes give away a
lot more for a lot less just look at
only fans yeah that's a good point but
we're talking lawyer fees here that's
not just of monthly $5.99
now that dude that he's just the he's
just the Beverly Hills version of a pay
Pig you know a construction worker
yeah just K he said you know he's a
little sub to Sophia he gives it all the
way to her little fin Dom
well they're both gonna have nothing bro
bro how [ __ ] how do you [ __ ] that up
that pad how do you want how are you how
are you that greedy
yeah everything that's the that's though
isn't that the wildest thing when people
get into entertainment and then that
they hit that switch and they start
going I deserve you know they start
getting that attitude oh I deserve all
of this stuff hey I understand if you've
been in the game a long time and someone
lowballs you in a certain situation you
say hey man I've been doing this job for
a while I know what works you can't you
can't under pay me like that that's one
thing yeah one year just shut up and
take your Millions
and she she wasn't even the one that was
editing it she didn't know work she
walked in and hosted it and then all of
the editing was her and they apparently
I don't know if this is true or not but
she said they record each episode for
three hours and she cuts it down to one
hour you know how much [ __ ] time that
takes oh yeah just audio oh yeah but you
have to literally listen to everything
for 3 app-- it probably takes like eight
hours to edit that down dude at least to
like I feel like it's so much more time
consuming than video for some reason cuz
it oh oh yeah like in terms of like
developing a narrative and [ __ ] like
that so that the our flows nicely and
there's no periods where yeah yeah with
the video at least you have like a
visual cues you're looking at you oh
this is when I this is when I did change
my shirt or whatever and it's easier to
like build a narrative mm-hmm I didn't
know we're long editing just or editing
three hours of audio just down to one
but I thought they do video and audio no
video just audio it's just audio yeah oh
my yeah get out of here yeah you just
trimming down a radio show oh my
goodness right oh my and I guess so I
guess Sophia like didn't want people to
know that it was Alex editing so every
time I Alex would post a picture of
herself on her story being like hey
editing a new episode can't wait for it
to go live tomorrow or whatever so feel
like hey can you take that down what
because I don't want like it makes me
uncomfortable because now people think
you're doing all the work
Oh red flag right there
red [ __ ] flag right there oh oh what
a piece of [ __ ] you are
um hey don't let anyone think you're
doing the work that you're actually
doing a lot of [ __ ] get out of here
bozo
I just watching this like oh my god so
now I think she's just doing the podcast
by herself or maybe she's getting
another co-host or something but the
funniest part about this now is that now
everyone's opinion of the show has
completely changed now that they
understand all this behind the scenes oh
she was doing all the cutting she was
doing all the work now there's no chance
of her coming back because yeah she does
away completely looks ungrateful an
[ __ ] and no one would want her back
they say oh it man you let your friend
do all this work and you've tried to
[ __ ] her over you don't deserve and she
can't go start another show yeah I don't
think she's a [ __ ] there too oh yeah
it's a wrap for her yep goodness man yep
well he does it it's a podcast speedrun
right there mm-hmm it's like the 6:9 of
mm-hmm of podcasting she blew up in like
two months
and then now she's out of the game see
ya didn't that it's kind of crazy how
much more I think we'll see that you
know is the six nines of media will they
blow up super quick and they like all
these records by way of some audience
and then they [ __ ] it up somehow yeah I
mean we yeah it's funny it's like that
happens it's happening more with it with
everything I mean every prank YouTuber
what the [ __ ] are those guys doing now
yeah and supreme patty oh yeah what the
view like we talked about him you know
later in the episode but like what I
brought his name up yesterday and I'm
like what the [ __ ]
I've when's the last time you saw a
video of him even Jomon your explore
page anything mm-hmm it's like people
have these exponential growth graphs and
they fall off just as quick yeah
I think also Instagram changed the
algorithm I think they stopped serving a
lot of that stuff yeah well I think for
a while the algorithm was just there the
discover page was doing its own thing
and those guys figured out how to game
it yeah and then um that I think they
just they tweaked whatever they were
doing
you know commenting on your own post and
goofy stuff like that yeah yeah yeah so
comment your favorite month
letter-by-letter
yeah what's your favorite type of cheese
did you write an essay last night tell
us about it letter by letter in the
comments you had damn bro that yeah it's
it's an end of an arrow the discover
page now is for me it's just it's
listening to what I say so it's just f1
cars and the same five pictures of the
same models that Instagram so
desperately is trying to get me to
follow it says yeah I'm not I'm not
following those people and and and our
own fleck fan accounts hey the amount of
me I see on my [ __ ] I'm like I don't
want to see my own yeah I hate it it
feels I did you know it just sucks
having to watch all of it and you know
cuz you can no three of you on you right
now like this is like old [ __ ] from from
like an old ass vlog member we're
sitting at a what's that what's that
food place called so kya no no the in
the place the healthy food place we used
to go all the time for lunch get away in
the mall buy healthy spot
oh oh it's man true food kids true food
Wow Wow
was it true food is true food kitchen
was their dad's got shut down and we saw
I saw chameleon air in there on several
lunches such a random celebrity I know I
know
millionaire
you